if you believe that each person's
life is a microcosm
of some larger pattern in other words
the fractal
faith what is exist as above so below
a pattern here will have a resonance on
a larger level
then why not believe
that human history is like a stage in
the gestation
of this informational syntactical
species that is of some different order
of magnitude than everything else going
on on this planet i mean
we don't know what it's like to be part
of
a pheromone-regulated termite hive
of millions of individuals but we do
know that the modalities that we create
you see that's epigenetic communication
pheromones it's genetically based but
then locally variant
but our
proclivity for this kind of thing for
the taking of
raw matter and alchemically uniting it
with ideas
with forms these mysterious invisible
things
impinging into our slice of time and
space from up some higher dimension
we take these intonations of
eternity and unite them with matter
and create these things which are made
of meaning and of
matter of light and of intentionality
and this tool-making process which then
has all kinds of consequences
rippling through the world of cultural
effects
becomes the kind of continuing carrot
for our appetition for future time
and as i said lying at the end of this
is the tool
which when correctly perceived is seen
to be
the self you know carlos castaneda bless
his heart
says you meet your double coming from
another dimension well
the mandayans had this same idea
they had this idea of this place called
misunia
which was the world of the light double
and at
death you you approached the boundary
condition
the edge of the attractor's domain and
entered into the turbulence what i've
called in talking about psychedelic
experiences the billows
where you meet the incoming billows this
highly chaotic state that precedes the
organized
or uh entry into the other
you know plato said uh time is the
moving image of eternity
this is one of his little laugherisms
and
i sort of think of that in terms of this
that
that from a higher dimension
which is sort of what we're trying to do
in this week is actually
very crudely visualize our own lives and
history from a higher dimension from a
higher dimension
it's all not completed
because that brings up the determinism
but
the plan is somehow all
visible from this higher dimension it
you can think of the plan
as a black and white diagram
and the completed part of the plan as
color
moving through the black and white so
when you're in hyperspace
looking at eternity you see the present
is the place where the color is
moving into the black and white yes
thomas aquinas had this notion of what
he called the nunc
stands the standing now
and it was uh caused
by the past and the future interfering
with each other
and causing the present so i do you know
the philosophy of
liveness which is this philosophy of
what he calls monads
which are tiny tiny versions of the
universe
each one complete within themselves and
they fill the universe in all directions
it's what's called a plenum
and i can imagine that each one of them
might be a bound energy state described
by this
so then you have this situation where it
is complete at all points
it is
somehow finalized and yet there is the
paradox
of becoming and perception of time is
driven
by the organism i mean it is somehow
a molecular phenomenon amplified and
transduced through these enormous
meaty bodies but it's something that is
happening because we're alive
chairs do not i think experience
time and the funny thing about us
this is perhaps worth pursuing
when you cut into a chair um
it doesn't change when you cut into a
living organism
you discover that everything is in
cyclical movement
the essence of being an organism seems
to be
that a flow of energy is trapped in a
form in a way that is not happening with
a chair or a tennis ball or a stone
the metabolism is this mysterious
process by which low-grade
material carbohydrates sugars and so
forth
are taken inside the system
and an alchemical process of
transduction
then raises the level of complexity
of this of the system and physiological
functions
can be fueled out of the chemical
cascades
that are then created when these complex
molecules that have been lifted to the
top of this energy cycle
are released and allowed to degrade
and then you get energy the energy to
move your body to think
and to feel but the sensation of time
is entirely rooted to the sensation of
being alive and of being
an organism
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you